positive news on the covid19 vaccine
front tonight governor steve sisselak
spoke on efforts to get more shots in
arms as a statewide outreach program
winds down sasha loftis joins us live
with more on what this means for las
vegas and really for all of nevada
ryan we spoke with one man who's one of
many who's gotten his kovid 19 shot in
the last few months now this is on the
heels of a federal plan to make sure
every person in every zip code in las
vegas is
immunized it's necessary it's necessary
christopher cohert just got his covid 19
vaccine in las vegas that's probably
going to get past this he says it makes
him feel so much safer and he's one of
many contributing to more inoculation
and less infection in clark county we
have made incredible progress
in our fight against covet 19. governor
steve siselek spoke on nevada's progress
thursday citing an 8.5 percent
positivity rate while 63 percent of
those eligible in our state have had at
least one shot the efforts of fema and
the efforts across the state of nevada
are why we're seeing this happen it's
largely thanks to the get out the vacs
program which allowed fema search teams
to directly reach out to zip codes with
low vaccination levels a diverse staff
with multilingual capabilities
contributed to the public acceptance
made an impact in vulnerable communities
and change local perception and
importantly increase vaccination rates
state leaders call the movement a
success but say our work isn't over just
yet just think about your loved ones
think about other people you're going to
be around officials and community
members like cohort urge you if you
haven't done so already
to go get your covid19 vaccine
now governor sysolak spoke on masked
mandates today as well he said at this
point our numbers here in clark county
aren't consistently low enough to take
those masks off he also mentioned
vaccine mandates he says he does not
anticipate any more in the future here
in clark county or nevada reporting live
in the newsroom tonight sacha loftis
live local now